[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
statut de sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission
à ne pas manquer si vous êtes un
amoureux du sport local c'est parti à
pour le sommaire multisports depuis ce
samedi à nouveau couvre-feu cette fois
ci à 18 heures est appliquée partout en
france un coup dur pour les clubs
sportifs certaines structures sans
réunissent tout de même pour continuer à
s'entraîner malgré les circonstances
exceptionnelles nous irons du côté de
juin josas les détails dans cette
émission
foot us les templiers d'elancourt ne
reprendront pas leur saison ce mois de
janvier à cause de la crise sanitaire le
premier match de l'année des élans
courtois est programmée au mois de mars
réactions à suivre automobile à coup de
projecteur sur un rallye 100% électrique
et 100% féminin alors rendez vous sont
organisés au départ de versailles du 9
au le 9 mai prochain pour recevront
l'organisatrice linda benezit dans ce à
magazine l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer à ces thèmes on
l'a appris jeudi soir dernier les
activités physiques scolaire et
extrascolaire en intérieur sont
suspendus jusqu'à nouvel ordre pour
faire face à l'épidémie de kobe de 19
dans les yvelines les gymnases et autres
complexes resteront donc fermés
les activités en extérieur reste quant à
elle possible pour le moment si elle ne
se déroule pas plus tard qu'au 18 heures
hors du nouveau couvre-feu décrété par
le gouvernement
ce couvre-feu abaissé à 18 heures est un
véritable casse tête pour les clubs
locaux qui ont tenté de reprendre les
entraînements depuis le mois de décembre
du côté de jouy en josas les
footballeurs s'entraîne à par exemple le
week-end dans la journée pour garder la
forme et être prêts en cas de reprise
des compétitions en reportage de bixente
mérian santisteva et patrick jacques de
dixmude
il attendait ça avec impatience les
footballeurs peuvent à nouveau fouler
leur pelouse de nombreux clubs amateurs
ont repris les entraînements des
retrouvailles entre coéquipiers après
deux mois d'arrêt le groupe l'ambiance
tout ça ça manque ça manque beaucoup
on va devoir les amis tout est fermé
donc forcément de se retrouver comme ça
le dimanche c'est top ça fait du bien
déjà de retrouver les copains de
retrouver l'esprit d'équipé faire un
petit peu d'activités physiques et
sportives en collectivité parce que
faire tout seul pendant confinement
s'est pas forcément très agréable
les horaires ont été adaptés selon les
clubs en raison du couvre-feu pour lui s
jouy en josas c'est un entraînement le
samedi matin et un autre le dimanche de
14h à 16h au programme des exercices
sans contact on verra aussi comment
comment la situation sanitaire évolué
puisque on peut pas jouer encore
complètement à part au contact par aux
oppositions c'est c'est quand même un
manque aussi pour nous le foot permet
col de faire des exercices sans contact
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de gamme comme
on peut le voir derrière voilà malgré
même si on fait pas de match à la fin
c'est pas grave au moins on s'est
retrouvés on affuble en quoi les clubs
avancent malgré tout à l'aveuglé sans
visibilité pour le reste de l'année on
en était à quatre matchs joués sur huit
normalement donc on a eu quatre matches
annulés déjà et on a une poule de douze
donc il faut au moins onze matches aller
pour pour terminer la phase aller et il
ya 22 matchs en tout sur toute la saison
et la saison se termine officiellement
le 30 juin
donc après on peut plus continuer de
faire la saison s'arrêtera le 30 juin
quoi qu'il arrive
l'équipe espère au moins finir la
première moitié de la saison pour
l'instant de solution semble privilégiée
par la fédération française de football
avancer de manière traditionnelle en
essayant de jouer autant de matches que
possible ou bien scindé les poules en
deux afin d'organiser des plus petits
championnats dans un système de playoffs
et play down si les clubs amateurs sont
en elles sont à l'arrêt chez eux au
niveau des compétitions certains clubs
qui ont le statut de haut niveau
continue les entraînements et surtout
les matches c'est le cas du club de
volley conflans andresy a joui l'équipe
senior masculine évolue en élite
l'équipe est actuellement à la 8e place
du classement pour nous parler du club
nous avons avec nous via écran interposé
philippe montaudouin le président du
club
bonsoir bonsoir alors est ce que vous
êtes satisfait ou plutôt énervé par ce
couvre-feu à 18h vous aviez peur d'un
nouveau confinement
finalement c'est un couvre-feu à 18
heures qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous à côté on n'est pas
concernée nous pour l'équipe élite avec
ce ce couvre feu de 18h l'eau nos
joueurs ont d'un laissez-passer pour s
entraîner donc pour nous ça n'a pas
changé mais moi ce qui m'a ce n'est pas
un énervement le sait c'est une
déception c'est la red des entraînements
pour les polygones heures on avait
repris depuis un mois il ajouté
d'ailleurs des des entraînements
supplémentaires pendant les vacances
vous rattraper l'arrêt des compétitions
et puis la période de confinement
l'avait eue et puis à nouveau les
enfants sont arrêtés donc on a plus que
l'équipe élite là au club là qu'il
fonctionne avec pas mal de difficultés
d'ailleurs alors vous n'avez pas joué le
week-end dernier est ce que ça permet à
l'équipe élite peut-être de de se
préparer peut-être ce nouveau calendrier
peut-être des car nous le calendrier en
fait ils et modifient leur il ya très
peu été modifié on a eu quelques matchs
reportés en début de saison à cause de
deux claques au vide ou de club tu
demande et des reports
là on est à nouveau dans le calendrier
on dirait normal si les choses se
passent bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres
d'autres complexités sanitaire on va
dire
un calendrier qui lui permet d'arriver à
la fin des matches aller au mois de
février avec tous les matchs joués on
aura un rattrapage aura deux matches le
week-end ou à jouer
charenton et puis un autre club
là on est en fait depuis effectivement
est bon dernier au repos et donc on est
en pleine préparation si on aura quinze
jours pour préparer la réception de
marseille un match très important
bailleur pour le trekkie aps c marseille
a très bien classés nous n'est pas trop
bien placé donc un match capital
justement ce match contre marseille
était prévue à 19h30
est-ce que l'horaire va changer oui ou
non on va à marseille nous a demandé de
le mettre à 19h en fait depuis le début
de cette saison un peu compliqué on
essaie de faire tout pour pour arranger
les gens dans la mesure où les trains
seront plus difficiles à prendre où il
faut trouver des hôtels
en fait on fait agences de voyages ont
pour tout vous dire mais chaque équipe
se met à disposition des visiteurs on la
range tout pour qu'il soit dans les
meilleures conditions
et puis on est bien reçu quand on va à
l'extérieur les gens nous offre des
casse cou pour repartir si on n'a pas de
quoi se restaurer c'est vraiment assez
sympa finalement dans cette crise
sanitaire
on trouve des valeurs sportives et de
camaraderie qui sont bien sympathiques
plus globalement vous jouez à huis clos
depuis plusieurs semaines est-ce que ça
a un impact peut-être sur sur les
joueurs et sur les résultats
oui forcément fait le fait de la part de
pas voir le 6e comme on dit le public ce
que conflent d'un petit gymnase qui bien
remplie avec des supporters sympathique
achats mais nous soutiennent bien bossé
ceci étant c'est la même chose pour les
deux équipes ce qui nous ennuie c'est la
visibilité pour le partenaire alors nous
on a mis en place
un live diffuse sur notre compte
facebook sur le fait accompli une page
ont diffusé match en direct pour que le
bas les spectateurs qui peuvent pas
venir puissent regarder match au caire
sept personnes qu'avec ses lives
finalement touche jusqu'à 1500 personnes
et on les aurait pas lent gymnase ont
finalement on a une belle visibilité
pour le club et ça pousse les joueurs
peut-être à se dépasser du coup ce live
vous mettez en place enfin je suis en
soit je crois qu faire dans le collège
les joueurs avec ces histoires là ne
sait plus de la com de lisibilité du
club depuis qu'il reste pas ici des
partenaires on leur avait promis de la
visibilité donc il faut il faut le faire
je pense que les joueurs sont vraiment
concentrés juste sur le match mais on
fait de gros travail de vidéo pour les
préparer au fait ce travail de deux
séances dati technique je suis vaut pour
pour mettre l'équipe dans les meilleures
dispositions pour affronter les forces
et les faiblesses d'ailleurs que de
l'équipement va recevoir après le reste
ensuite bonne non c'est pas très
important pour eux alors vous allez
disputer pour l'instant sept matchs
depuis le début de la saison est-ce que
vous pensez que la saison élite va aller
jusqu'au bout écoutez ou si je suis pas
je suis pas dans le milieu médical
non franchement je veux on vit au jour
le jour vous savez depuis la fin d'année
dernière où on est une saison qui
finalement a peu apporté entre lima et
puis et puis la reprise de cette saison
a fait commencer quelques unes de nos
équipes nationales dauphine est obligé
d'arrêter nationale 3 est arrêté
apprendre à faire reprendre les jeunes à
comparaître les jeunes que moi ce que
j'ai souvent croisé doigt ceux ci nous
reste l'équipe élite pour parler un peu
de volley ball
ils ont mené à des plus gros clubs de
régions de france
j'espère que ça va durer longtemps et
puis que donc on considérera que
finalement une douzaine de personnes
dans un grand espace comme n'est comme
gymnase n'est pas si risqué que sa
dernière question à philippe entonnoir
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
la suite de la saison
moi j'ai plein soit le premier se voit
déjà c'est que tous les joueurs du club
puisse reprendre le chemin du gymnase
parce que ça s'est fait pas faire de
sport phare de volley ball quand on est
des passionnés
c'est compliqué après une reprise de nos
championnats pour tous les autres
équipes et puis aussi pour le volley
loisir pour qu'ils puissent même sur une
cheminée une saison qui serait courte
avec quelques matches en moins d'autres
systèmes d système de play-offs 2 de
championnat un peu réduit sur la durée
au moins qu'ils puissent reprendre une
activité qu'on est peut-être la chance
en septembre 2002 d'avoir enfin une
saison normale
et puis surtout le maintien de notre
équipe élite parce que c'est la vitrine
du club
merci à vous d'être intervenu dans cette
émission bon courage pour la suite de la
saison continuera évidemment à vous
suivre sur tv à 78 on va maintenant
parler d'eux à football america les
templiers d'elancourt l'un des meilleurs
clubs de france ne débuteront pas leur
saison à la fin alors janvier et
débuteront leur saison au mois de mars
par dont les instances ont décidé de
décaler la rentrée au mois de mars donc
des images de bixente mérian santisteva
un montage de zellige à la rentrée
décalée pour les templiers les élans
courtois ne commenceront pas leur saison
ce mois de janvier comme d'habitude leur
premier match de deuxième division est
programmée début mars contre les deux
courses de nantes
la décision a été prise par la
fédération française il devrait
également y avoir moins de matches cette
saison
la saison va être écourtée à cause du
courant d'un virus
j'en espère faire le plus de matches
possibles donc du coup aller en pleurs
fait gagner la frustration est énorme à
la fois pour le club est à la fois pour
le joueur surtout quand on est
extrêmement motivé mais on a la chance
en fait d'avoir une famille templiers
qui restent très soudés dans cette
période compliquée decaux vide avec des
entraînements plus limité donc oui oui
il ya une frustration c'est évident une
saison décalé des incertitudes sur le
calendrier deux éléments qui ont
entraîné des baisses de sponsoring pour
cette saison 2021
le club doit donc faire face à la crise
et s'adapter non le club n'est pas en
danger il a nécessité en fait qu'on
prenne des décisions stratégiques et on
continue à prendre des décisions
stratégiques aujourd'hui pour protéger
des intérêts du club pour vivre dans ce
minima en limitant les investissements
par exemple on se pose la question de
savoir si on maintient ou pas l'arrivée
d'un joueur américain cette année
s'il n'y a pas de saison n'y a aucun
aucune raison de faire des engagements
financiers pour être prêt pour la
reprise les templiers continue à
s'entraîner régulièrement rendez vous
début mars pour la reprise de la saison
si le contexte sanitaire le permet un
mot de voile à présent le skipper louis
burton est toujours en cours sur ce
vendée globe 2021 et réalise une superbe
performance ce sportif originaire de
rambouillet est actuellement en train de
remonter vers les sables d'olonne dans
l'océan atlantique
au classement les viennois est
actuellement 2e après plus de 80% de
courses effectuées le navigateur
enregistré cette vidéo pour expliquer sa
situation il est actuellement en train
de traverser le pot-au-noir regarder
surtout après des journées rapide
les après-midis rapide dans
dans l'alizé bien établis comme c'était
le cas cet après midi voilà pour les
éviter
et voilà
charles
louis burton devrait arriver dans moins
de deux semaines aux sables d'olonne
pour boucler son tour du monde
une autre aventure s'est terminée à
vendredi à dernier en arabie saoudite le
dakar à 2021 2 illinois ont participé à
ce rendez vous jean pierre gars en 57
ans originaire de montesson comme
copilote de christian lavieille md
rallye sport
il ya également jean pierre strugo / ph
sport le pilote de 74 ans est lui
originaire de chatou au classement ce
dernier termine 34ème du général jean
pierre garcin termine quant à lui 11e
avec cinq heures et trois minutes de
retard sur le vainqueur
stéphane peterhansel les 2 heavy noah
pourrait participer l'année prochaine à
la 44e édition du dakar le rendez vous
sera une nouvelle fois organisé en
arabie saoudite l'année un prochaine on
continue à parler automobile c'est une
grande première un rallye à 100%
électrique et 100% féminin partira de
versailles le 9 mai à prochain pour nous
parler de ce rendez vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau à linda benezit
fondatrice de nature l aventure on soit
alors un rallye 100% électrique et 100%
féminin c'est une grande première une
première mondiale
tout à fait dans une très belle
transition après le dakar donc justement
des femmes qui vont partir à bord d une
voiture électrique donc le top départ
est prévu donc pour le 9 mai prochain
donc une course 100 % féminine et 100%
en voiture électrique quel est le
concept alors le concept est de mixer
des étapes en voiture électrique et des
étapes en trek pour être plus proche de
la nature
on va vraiment soutenir des projets en
faveur de l'environnement et donc c'est
une semaine de challenge dédié aux
femmes
alors pourquoi justement un rallye 100%
féminin alors en fait on a voulu
soutenir des projets féminins le comme
vous disiez le dakar est quand même le
sport automobile le rallye automobile et
est plutôt traditionnellement masculins
donc c'est très bien
voilà c'est bien donc c'est très bien de
féminiser finalement ce sport automobile
vous allez donc partir de versailles
pourquoi parce qu'en fait donc je suis
originaire de versailles et on assure
versailles donc un pôle de recherche
scientifique sur les nouvelles mobilités
donc c'est tout naturellement que la
ville de versailles a accepté d'être
partenaire de notre
événement parce qu'on partage les mêmes
valeurs alors quelle sera la suite du
parcours donc départ de versailles pour
aller alors en fait on organisait un
prêt de rang village départ le dimanche
9 mai donc on donne rendez-vous vraiment
à tous les franciliens pour pouvoir nous
rencontrer et d'ailleurs même les autres
et ensuite on se rendra en région savoie
et haute savoie avec une arrivée finale
à evian et quelle est l'idée de le
concept vous l'avez dire c'est traverser
la france mais c'est avec une boussole
avec une carte c'est ça c'est un rallye
d'orientation c'est ça le concept
rallier dont il n'y a pas de notion de
vitesse 100 % en navigation autonomes
donc carte et boussole les gps sont
interdits d'ailleurs tout comme les
téléphones puisque les équipages vont
naviguer avec un road book alors
l'événement se déroulera du coup au mois
de mai 1 je disais du 9 au 15 mai est ce
qu'il pourra quand même se tenir malgré
le contexte sanitaire
alors on va tout faire on espère nous en
tout cas qui sera maintenue tout est
prévu pour pouvoir maintenir cette
course évidemment on sera dépendant des
décisions du gouvernement
je crois qu'on a besoin en ce moment
quand même de deux projets et de
danville de participer de prendre l'air
donc si on ne devait toutefois pas
pouvoir partir en reporterait
l'événement alors vous l'avez dit
l'événement sera 100% électrique c'est
une volonté c'est un peu dans l'air du
temps on peut dire absolument
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de challenge
et les innovations technologiques et de
pouvoir dire qu'avec une voiture
électrique on est capable de faire un
rallye tous les véhicules seront
électriques 100 % électrique au niveau
l'organisation alors un niveau
d'organisation sera sur des véhicules
hybrides parce qu'on est obligés quand
même d'avoir un plus d'autonomie qu'une
voiture électrique pour pouvoir soutenir
et en tout cas assister nos équipages
alors si tant est ouvert à tout le monde
vraiment oui toutes les femmes donc avec
ou sans expérience
il faut avoir évidemment le permis de
conduire depuis au moins deux ans mais
on n'est pas obligé d'avoir de
l'expérience en rallye automobile
alors est ce qu'il est et complet ce
rallye automobile s'attend pas encore
pas encore donc les inscriptions sont
toujours ouvertes
on donne rendez vous à toutes les femmes
tous les jeudis soirs puisque on
organise des réunions d'information ou
donne tous les détails sur cette
aventure
on a aujourd'hui cet équipage
ile-de-france qui sont inscrits et des
équipages de province donc il reste des
places on sait encore des places mais
comment fait du coup pour s'inscrire on
participe d'abord aurait une
l'information d'abord pour bien
comprendre le concept et ensuite on peut
s'inscrire directement en ligne
vous allez également avoir un parrain
prestigieux pour cet événement justement
regardez un extrait oui allô oui alors
linda salut c'est franck dubosc j'espère
que tu vas bien
bah oui ça lui franck et coutumes en
plein tournage bon dit moi je t'appelle
propos à propos du rallye je m'inscris
je m'inscris et voilà je vais trouver
mon équipage ce soit moi moi moi et moi
je pars je parle ici
voilà la grande aventure c'est pour moi
elles sont mais je suis ravi que ça me
plaise 5 mais c'est un rallye féminin
tendance a que pour les femmes
il a commencé pour les fans m'avaient
excuse moi mais enfin pourquoi encore
pour les femmes toujours pour les femmes
tout pour les femmes
excuse moi simplement personnellement ça
ne me dérange pas du tout qui est que
des femmes
non juste un but bien si je peux pas
venir on va
qu'est-ce que je peux faire je te
propose une chose c'est d'être le
parrain par la marraine
le parrain c'est valider ça je serais
pour parrain dans l'approché nenni alors
pourquoi franck dubosc vous voulez un
artiste français 1 plutôt masculin pour
soutenir toutes ces femmes qui vont
partir à l'aventuré
et quand on lui a proposé franck dubosc
est un homme au grand coeur donc c'est
naturellement qu'il a accepté de devenir
le parrain de cette aventure il va
s'impliquer dans l'aventuré en fait
c'est lui qui va donner le top départ
depuis le village de départ le nez
dimanche 9 mai et on devrait l'avoir
avec nous pour l'arrivée alors c'est une
première édition est ce qu'il y en aura
d'autres dont future esplanade de j'ai
déjà deux programmes et peut-être oui
tout à fait michael donc on a déjà une
édition 2022 france et on ajoute la
norvège et d'ici 2025 ces cinq pays
qu'on a qu'on ira visiter
donc l'idée c'est de monter en puissance
d'année en année ce sera tout à fait
chaque année on va ajouter un pays
supplémentaires
toutes les divisions toutes les éditions
pardon reviendront tous les ans donc
rendez vous sur l'une de nos aventures
avec peut-être plus de participantes
peut-être selon gilles fauré on limitera
de toute façon nos équipages à 30 pour
chacune de nos éditions parce qu'on veut
un rallye à taille humaine et le départ
sera toujours de versailles alors pour
l'audition france oui et pour les autres
éditions offre un village départ dans
les pays où nous serons d'accord parle
pas de versailles forcément marseille
forcément mais ça reviendra peut-être
faire ça merci beaucoup pour votre
passage sur ce plateau le rendez-vous
sera donc organisée au départ de
versailles le 9 mai un prochain si les
conditions sanitaires le permettent
évidemment télé 70 sera bien sûr présent
sur cet événement on termine ce 7,8
sport part du golfe c'est une golfeuse
professionnelle à suivre sur le circuit
a féminin m'allonger daly a réalisé à 27
ans l'une des plus belle saison de sa
carrière en 2020 en réalisant deux top
10 est sportifs qui s'entraînent
régulièrement au club de la boule ici un
verset de grandes ambitions et vise les
jo de 2024 regardez son portrait trouver
le bon mouvement le bon dosage
régulièrement la golfeuse
professionnelle madjid ali 27 ans répète
ses gammes sur les parcours illinois et
notamment sur celui du golf de la
bouillie à versailles un cocon qu'elle a
rejoint à l'âge de 14 ans ç'a toujours
été un grand club
depuis tout petit je suis arrivé ici à
l'âge de 14 ans et c'est vrai que le
racing c'était le club sportif avec les
tous les bons espoirs
et donc c'était j'étais vraiment ravi
d'être accueillis ici et j'étais surtout
très fier de pouvoir représenter le club
en gaule force de pouvoir me battre pour
les couleurs bleu ciel et blanc sur
l'apprentissage du haut niveau est
également passé par les états unis à 18
ans la golfeuse parfaire ses études dans
l'université d'arizona pendant quatre
années un vrai plus souvent cette fan de
tiger woods quand je suis arrivé là bas
c'était vraiment une autre dimension
c'est à dire que là bas les
infrastructures tout est mis en place
pour le sportif pour qu'il se sente bien
pour qu'ils peuvent
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses surtout
notamment par rapport à l'aspect un peu
mentale l'aspect stratégique très
positif là bas ils sont vraiment c'était
c'était une belle expérience de vie une
expérience bénéfique en 2016 manon
gilali passe professionnel elle est
aujourd'hui la quatrième français sur le
ladies european tour après une année
2009 un réussi là j'ai eu deux années
qui ont été plutôt satisfaisante la
cette année je fini 33e européenne oran
qui ça a été ma meilleure année depuis
mon passage pro danger dali veut
continuer sa progression pour accomplir
ses rêves participer un jour à une
solesmes cup une compétition qui oppose
l'europe aux états unis mal manger des
lièvres également faire partie de
l'aventuré des jeux olympiques de 2024
il va falloir gagner des tournois il va
falloir pas formés parce que il faut
marquer pas mal de point au niveau
ranking mondial et le ranking mondial
malheureusement quand on est en europe
c'est dur de marquer des points par
rapport au tournoi qui aux états unis
donc va falloir parfait en europe avant
de penser aux jeux olympiques m'allonger
delhi espère réussir sa rentrée sur le
circuit européen en 2021 objectif de sa
saison remporter une victoire et
intégrer le top 15 en fin d'année
c'est la fin de cette émission merci le
avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]